tearing down other human beings for your
own self-interest is the dog [__] move
of humanity it's the internet though
right now Gary you're an enormous
rewards no no the internet doesn't
reward like it's humans people love to
blame the internet people love to blame
social media people love to blame
politicians it's you [__] face stop
being a dick every person that has ever
done the internet knows that this man's
existence and has been inspired or
influenced or entertained all right
ladies and gentlemen a man who is an nft
Super Bowl in a NFL stadium not only
last year but this upcoming year
obviously an author five-time New York
Times bestseller ladies and gentlemen
Gary Vee
let's go
hey your titles are long I don't think I
would have been able to do a full intro
and we were a little bit late because
one of our computers just decided to
update out of nowhere I heard so we
apologize and we thank you for making
time for us brother how are you doing
Garrett Wilson offensive
let's go the future's bright for your
Jets team Gary I feel I feel very
confident I think Breece Hall would have
been number one or two in Rookie of the
Year as well and so yeah there's a lot
of things obviously the quarterback
situation is something we have to figure
out but there's a lot of pieces in place
so do you think because you are getting
a kind of a taste that the Jets were
almost good at football this year that's
why whenever they would lose you'd be so
[__] mad do you do you think that is
I've been so [__] mad no no this year
though it felt like you guys had a
chance right it's almost like you were
grasping at Hope a little bit no and
then the Jets come back here let's all
calm down that video and I first of all
I love all of you and so I'm very aware
of what's always going on let alone a
massive Global show like this just so
you know I know what like some weird
dude in the basement in Ohio is doing I
definitely know what you guys are doing
I had to cover it so
that was do did you watch that football
game the Browns had won like I I wait to
the last second of every football game
if it's still within scoring distance to
not let my emotions go happy or sad but
that game was over over yeah and so of
course I lost my mind it wasn't winning
that Browns game and that was a decade
of frustration being let out yes just to
remind everybody so let's talk about
this hold on hold on I gotta say this
ball fast shoot football fan though I
gotta say something go ahead there is no
distant second to the Jets playoff trout
right now we have not been there for 12
years so we are pent up and I'm saying
it right now early so you can clip this
a lot next year we're gonna [__]
dominate next year
the Jets what does that mean though okay
that means ten and seven
but that's still good I'm good I'm
pumped about ten and seven so is that
what the expectations are though we're
gonna make the playoffs maybe get a
playoff win for the first time 12 years
this is uh this is a very very talented
bunch there's a lot left to be done
we've got a draft we've got free agency
is Aaron Rodgers your quarterback or
what exactly my intuition yeah first of
all I don't want to give up on Zach I'm
so tired you're a good person for that
which you are you're the only one yes
it's also logical like Geno Smith was
productive this year we gave up on him
when you were like seven yeah right like
people are giving up two seconds
yeah you got punched in the face
I guess the Zach Wilson situation kind
of exactly Zach got punched he got
punched emotionally not physically like
you know but Zach is here Zach is that
Rock Bottom which actually will allow us
to get a very good read on him because
he's absolutely at a Crossroads agreed
and we took the [__] kid number two
24 months ago I'm not ready to be like
it's over everyone's so [__] up the
set so you don't want Aaron Rodgers Jets
on Aaron Rodgers I want it when it comes
to Aaron or Jimmy G or Derek Carr I
think Tannen Hill's probably in play as
well of the College of the crew that's
out there I want to know which one wants
to come in and realize they're in a
great situation and try to win some
playoff games that go to this game next
year but I also want somebody who's got
five to ten percent of their energy
capacity to try to help the kid long as
well that's right so that's what I'm
interested in AJ has a question for you
what about Baker Mayfield you left him
out there is he a possibility
listen I think he's a possibility it
hasn't hit my radar I don't know why
that hasn't it one more follow-up what
like out of everything you do is
actually AQ shipping right here we were
wondering if someone asked you hey Gary
what do you do for a living what do you
tell them I'm an entrepreneur you do
everything I do so much [__] I'm an
entrepreneur like I think that's the
definition like you want to run
different things and yeah it's a little
bit of a renaissance man Hawk like like
it's just like I like doing a lot of
[__] is that your next book renaissance
man yeah hawk or yeah with the Hawks
that'd be sweet yeah
is that the next book time now the next
book is jab jab jab left hook oh which
is your content to charge people correct
Hook was a huge book for me I wrote 10
years ago of like this is how you
actually make content on the internet
right now content is changing the tick
tockification of all social media
everyone watching here now actually has
a chance to make one clip about pizza or
sports or gardening and it can hit and
it can change the course of their lives
yeah we did it and we were dumb grouping
yeah
look at us hey look at us Gary I would
have thought ensued by Brett your
quarterback my quarterback he's suing me
by the way that was an amazing season
for the Jets if he didn't get hurt in
Tennessee I think the Jets win that
Super Bowl they went in and beat a 10-0
Titans team in Nashville
31-7 and I was like wait a minute it
might happen and we lost literally every
game
that year as well yeah yeah
before and after every statement right
can I see two questions these lawsuits
they don't put the allegedly no they
don't they edited that out of there
anyway sorry about it it's been a while
since I've been actually on the show in
that time you've become come probably
the most important person in sports
Gary that's an absurd statement it's not
it is an absurd statement even if you
look at the reaction of your family here
they all know you are 80 000 times more
important than you were five years ago
in the genre of sports culture do you
feel you know I understand you you
punted in front of lots of people
there's pressure with that right
WrestleMania WrestleMania was massive
you were amazing thank you
but do you feel extra pressure now that
you're the establishment that's
interesting because uh we're so
independent though so are we in the
establishment or are we still the pirate
because we're making more money than
most of the establishment we're still
independent though so I feel good about
the fact that we don't have people
controlling what we can talk about what
we don't talk about I love that I think
that's a big deal that is the deal but
yeah we have to I mean with this whole
lawsuit thing we knew I knew one was
probably coming at some point just
because the way we operate you know
we're loose we're wide open you're loose
we're wide loose we're wide open I don't
think we mean any illness intense we
just mean like how do we make the most
entertaining [__] and we try not to be
negative ever because I think it's very
easy like I think you have been a great
um Trailblazer for this movement
negative Sports is easy like burying
somebody's easy you get a lot of clips
from that but I remember being in a
locker room and some of my teammates are
getting killed I'm like yo there's a
good [__] dude he's just so happened
to have a couple bad games so we try to
stay as positive as possible it's one of
my biggest biggest reasons that I really
[__] with you guys on some real [__]
tearing down other human beings for your
own self-interest is the dog [__] move
of Hunan it's the internet though right
now Gary yeah
no exactly people love to blame the
internet people love to blame social
media people love to blame politicians
it's you [__] face stop being a dick
that's a great point but you know just
as much as I do when you put a
scoreboard on every piece of content
which they have and people are trying to
make a living out of it whenever I think
people get addicted to those numbers
people definitely get addicted to those
numbers but it doesn't mean it's right
no agreed but that's why I say whenever
I say Internet it's like the internet
almost rewards no no the internet
doesn't reward like it's humans that are
doing the rewarding the social media
pipes are empty Pat they're [__]
empty there's people that make stuff and
there's people that consume stuff and I
think it's time we take a step back and
realize why are we hurting that we get
micro joy out of someone else hurting
what part of you is happy when
somebody's [__] on LeBron James what
part of you is Happy what's your point
though to that point like somebody just
got paid 8 million a year at the age of
75. yeah to [__] on LeBron James though
like and that's not the internet though
that's TV right so it's almost like a
societal problem well that's right
that's the point like like everyone
wants to blame everybody but themselves
and so you're in control of yourself
hell yeah do you want to compromise like
do you want to make a bag by [__] on
people 24 7 you got to live with that
[__] like like so great you have a
[__] Lambo but you don't sleep great
at night who's making that trade a lot
of people yeah but guess what okay
that's not an interesting [__] trade
for me and everybody's watching you
don't have to follow that [__] there's
plenty of Alternatives and a million
people living happy not doing that isn't
it crazy there's some people that just
have no conscience it's crazy like we've
been laying down at night they just [__]
somebody over completely and then they
just sleep soundly and then they wake up
the next day and they're like I'm gonna
follow defamation loss I would actually
there's people that do that there's
people that could do that I would
actually argue that it's the complete
reverse of that it's not that they don't
have conscious it's that they're
actually hurting
actually the realest [__] statement
how do you change that oh yeah by having
compassion and empathy for people that
are hurting concussion cream empathy
there's also that that works too that's
also a thing Ty has a question for you
Gary Gary the last couple times we've
talked to you've talked about buying the
Jets yes how realistic is that if you're
my Ferry okay but what happens like if
let's say in the crowdsourcing let's say
let's say the Johnson cell in three
years and I'm not financially ready and
it goes somewhere else yeah somewhere or
so it'll start winning if they start
winning and what you're expecting to pay
right now is much different especially
when you you're much smarter than this
thing that winning has an impact on the
sale of a team come on I don't know you
don't know what price what part on the
price yeah definitely on the price
definitely on the price of the team
there's teams that set like if you look
at how teams sell they're just such rare
assets like like the Panthers weren't
[__] crushing it when they're selling
for a record price the Bronco like it's
just people want teams and New York's
going to be expensive regardless it's
not like I want the [__] Saints you
know or the [__] Colts you know like
you know and so and so I want a certain
team it's gonna be what it's going to be
I'm gonna keep trying long before I ever
made a video on the internet when I was
in fourth grade I'm like I'm gonna do
this seventh grade 12th grade like 20.
and so this is my goal hell yeah that's
a good goal it's a good dream vision
board you do a lot of that and you
accomplish them all I gotta tell you
like what's scary is I genuinely think
it's gonna happen what's even more
exciting is if it doesn't happen I
[__] tried are you a hedge fund guy
at all or no no isn't that where you got
to get to to get the amount of money to
potentially do that do you have a plan
on getting to the money
yeah I'm building businesses I'm
building you know v-friends is an
intellectual property it's a Pokemon
meet Sesame Street Sick by the way Anna
has had success a lot of nfts have
failed completely the V friends is still
going very strong and then
congratulations thank you and Vayner X
is a 350 million dollar Revenue business
2 000 employees that I started from
scratch with my brother 13 years ago
I'll do that for another decade hell
yeah that's a multi-billion dollar exit
if I do it properly you think you can
get to it I think I can get to it let's
go go get it V con next year Lucas Oil
Stadium yes Beacon and Gary B is up
there Gary B's up there the humble uh
hippo what about patient Panda oh
patience
who said that come on come on we know
your [__] come on come on we're on the
Internet G we're on the Internet G we
know Gary intuitive iguana was in the
commercial Fair where vikon was gonna be
boom and the patient pain we take it all
in I appreciate it and the Gary B came
in yeah
some of the [__] you focus on we're like
well that's not for us but then the
other stuff we're like seems like if
Gary's paying attention of your takes on
this show it's not for me but that's
life well we just see the way you're
operating we have Gary's if Gary thinks
this is of importance probably a good
idea for us to take that yeah
and by the way that's what's going on
with y'all like I you know we got to
talk for a few seconds before max age
one of the most enjoyable things for me
is watching other people win back to the
reverse of what we were just talking
about we've we've been on each other's
radar for a long time watching all of
you build what you guys have been
building has been a great joy and I I
genuinely wish you so much success and
the happiness and escapism that you
bring for so many people that watch this
show is very meaningful and I cheer for
you guys heavy man that's very doubly
yeah very very nice you say thank you
again thank you Gary now with that being
said our takes will probably be more for
you if the Jetsons suck yeah you know
what I mean that's true yeah you have
the Jets were a little bit better you
know what I mean you gotta appreciate
something I love being a Jets fan you
know who I feel bad for 35 year old
Patriot fans oh that's that guy right
down there he's 27. well let me explain
the Badness sure you actually believe
you achieved something yeah
oh yes oh yeah oh yeah
it's the six Super Bowl championships
that's right
attention an NBA championship that's
right an NHL championship two baseball
championships you are the greatest
athlete of all time two MLS cops don't
forget about the revolution
that's right but but it's terrible from
here on for the rest of his life when
your self-esteem is wrapped up into a
team that has
with your actual life it can get
confusing that doesn't mean that you're
bad but it's confusing I think that
Chief fans are starting to get confused
I definitely know that Golden State
Warriors fans are confused because I was
doing Tech investing when the warriors
were not good nobody in [__] SF knew
a clue didn't even know where golden
state was they they wouldn't know Chris
Mullins
right they didn't know them at all and
all of a sudden the Warriors started
getting good and all these Google and
Facebook and tech people were like
Warriors those [__] are so confused
yeah and they don't even know what
basketball is because Steph doesn't play
with basketball plus that plays a
different style of basketball and nobody
else can play what are you doing you're
an Uber Facebook yes all of them but
listen all of them oh yeah being a Jets
fan is phenomenal you you deal with
adversity at scale
the world's against you I love it I love
when all the [__] get on Twitter and
they're like you [__] said I'm like
okay I want to eat all that [__]
yeah and then when we [__] rise and
win it I'm gonna [__] Stick it to
everyone yeah we want a regular season
game against the Browns I lost my
[__] mind could you imagine when the
Jets win the Super Bowl yeah yeah
sure and then Gary B will come in with a
house
we appreciate you yeah here's you lose
your mind
[__] [__] receipts
[__] you Jacoby [__] we're [__]
[__] hold on we start the
receipts conversation every single week
every time we picked the Jets game it
was like we don't want to end up on
Gary's [__] video yeah but we do
think the Jets are going to lose this
one I want a little bit of a run we
appreciate the hell out of here you're
the man such a pleasure love you keep
crushing ladies and gentlemen thank you
so much
thanks man appreciate you thank you very
much
[Music]